ah mais vous êtes là vous vous souvenez
de tout ca trù rythme inférieur dans les
reportages ou dans les séries où vous
avez truc où le la personne fait quelque
chose c'est à nous c'est vrai vous êtes
là salut à vous peuple et 2 internet
nous sommes à la vidéo numéro 8 de ce
calendrier de l'avent d'avant d'avant
noël d'avant noël évidemment alors le
jeu vous rappel visuel principe oui ça
fait des fautes ça fait plaisir
une vidéo tous les jours à 6 heures du
matin jusqu'au 24 ou soulager traite
d'un sujet ou pas forcément ça dépend de
la densité de la deuxième partie à
savoir vous présentez une idées de
cadeaux de noël parmi les choses que
j'ai et que j'aime bien vous présente un
peu tous les kiffe ce soit un livre
enjeu de taille ce ne sont pas des mieux
sponsorisés voilà ça c'est dit et
aujourd'hui je voudrais parler du
dernier livre de bernard werber qui est
sorti au mois d'octobre et qui s'appelle
depuis l'au delà
alors ça c'est pas le livre que j'ai
acheté pour la simple et bonne raison
que si vous avez suivi cette vidéo que
vous pouvez regarder à l'appareil si
dans un petit et je mets le lien dans la
description
l'année dernière j'avais le plaisir de
le rencontrer pour son livre demain les
chats et depuis on a gardé le contact
ensemble et c'est symbolique on a des
discussions très très cool et avant la
sortie de ce livre vous n'avez renvoyer
quelque chose d'un peu magique pour moi
ce sont les épreuves non corrigées
c'est la version d'avant la version est
donc j'avais pu le lire ici
et du coup j'ai quand même reçu ensuite
cette version là que je n'ai pas du tout
ouverte et que je vous fait gagner à la
fin de cette vidéo
voilà je viens juste d'avoir l'idée
c'est pour ça que j'étais moi même
surpris de ce convoi je me dis voilà
concours personne n'avait prévu
le livre est très bien hahaha
c'était mon argumentation le livre est
très bien pourquoi parce que ça fait
longtemps qu'ils n'avaient pas un roman
qui m'avait surpris dans les 20
premières pages je vais pas vous dire le
pourquoi du coin du comment mais j'aurai
la 20e page et intimiste qui se fait et
c'est souvent un piste de fin de film ou
de fin de livre
c'est en régularité d'être à la fin
d'une histoire et on l'a très rapidement
en quelques chapitres et en ça j'ai
trouvé ça très forts qu'eux ils puissent
arriver à me surprendre comme ça
pourquoi lui spécifiquement parce que
dans donc dans mes anciennes vidéos
qu'en dehors quand j'ai déjà parlé de
berlin faire bien je vous avais dit que
j'avais tout lui en fait depuis les
fourmis depuis 1991 quand les formes qui
était sorti j'ai commencé à le dire
jusqu'à la suite celui-ci toujours un
thème l'au delà
mais rien à voir avec ce qu'il a fait
avec les thanatonautes par exemple on
est sur un fantôme qui mène une enquête
j'aime bien le point de vue on est sûr
de la sf un peu réaliste quand même
c'est assez intéressant en fait comment
les lignes elle bouge dans ce bouquin au
point que l'histoire est toujours
crédible malgré ce côté surréaliste du
fantôme enquêteurs il ya pas mal de
choses que j'ai aimé dans le livre la
dualité entre le fantôme et son frère
qui nous rappelle quelque chose qu'on
connaît forcément a pas forcément avec
un frère ou une soeur
mais cette notion de complémentarité qui
est toujours très présente
il ya je pense je crois enfin j'en suis
sûr parce que j'ai posé la question en
vrai mais je me posait déjà la question
avant et c'est pour ça que je suis allé
jusqu'à lui demander qui a des
références à des personnes que l'on
connaît nous une manière publique sous
forme de critiques à l'intérieur de
livres dans le livre ils sont
représentés par d'autres personnages
auraient la même fonction que mais ça
représente
vraiment des gens que werner ap
rencontrés au cours de sa vie donc voilà
je vous le dis il ya un jeu aussi à
faire par rapport à ça la fin du livre
j'ai envie de vous dire c'est pas le
plus important il ya quand même une
résolution
j'aime ce type de bernard werber c'est à
dire des phrases courtes concise
ça donne un rythme on a des gros plan
aussi des mouvements de caméra vraiment
à la lecture de l'histoire dans les
images qu'on se fait où il à ce style là
qui parfois est critiqué mais en fait le
fonds a plus d'importance que le style
et le style n'est pas lourd ce qui rend
service en fait à l'histoire et au
rythme de cette histoire je ne sais pas
si je suis minute l'air et on retrouve
tous ces ingrédients qui fait qu'on aime
mais regarde herbert c'est pour moi ça
fait partie d'un de ses meilleurs
bouquin je je je crois qu'en termes de
ventes c'est pas du tout à une des
meilleures ventes il se perd pas dans
cet homme vente
et pourtant je pense sincèrement c'est
l'un des bouquins que j'ai préféré l'un
des livres j'ai pas si c'est pas l'heure
de jeu relatif vous pas dire bouquin
ainsi que le papillon des étoiles
m'avait fait ça aussi m'avait beaucoup
beaucoup interpellé énormément plu au
niveau du sénat je vous propose quelque
chose
deux choses le concours évidemment je
vous propose un concours qui va avoir un
sens particulier je m aujourd'hui un
message sur twitter avec un hashtag le
hashtag
policard dernière ouvert vers orly car
le hashtag que vous voyez sa fiche et la
voilà juste ici et je vais mettre un
tweet sur twitter vous allez répondre
aux tweets pour essayer de gagner le
livre là mais mieux que ça en fait pour
participer il faut répondre aux tweets
en posant une question que vous aimeriez
que je pose
a berné un pervers est ce que je vous
propose c'est ça qui va être cool c'est
de le voir en janvier de sélectionner
une partie dû aux questions de faire le
tri de prendre des questions qui
représente l'ensemble des questions etc
et de faire une vidéo où je me fais
votre porte parole et je pose les
questions que vous voulez que je lui
pose qu'est les rapports avec sa vie sa
manière de travailler le contenu de ses
livres certaines de ces histoires ce que
vous voulez hein ça peut être tout à
fait largy imaginez vous rencontrer
bernard werber dans votre vie et il n'a
pas trop le temps et vous dit tu peux me
poser une question celle que tu n'en
resterait plus qu'à demi frère tu peux
poser une question celle que tu veux
mais dépêche toi parce que après je m'en
veux et là tu as une seule question à
poser c'est quoi la question tu lui
poses et les opportunités que je vous
donne dans cette vidéo la donc le lien
vers le tweak yvel dans la description
sur ce twitt vous répondez à la question
vous êtes marié posé et vous retrouvez
le tweet ça ce sera la condition pour
participer au concours et je ferai le
tirage au sort en janvier uniquement
l'histoire de collecter toutes vos
questions d'ici deux mois de décembre et
je ferai le tournage avec lui en jambes
voilà je pense que j'ai tout dit en tout
cas je vous recommande de le lire si
vous avez l'occasion avant et pourquoi
je fais tirage au sort qu'en janvier
parce que quand on aura le nom du
gagnant ou de la gagnante
je lui demanderais lors des freinages de
le dédicacer donc vous l'avez eu ou
achetés avant vous aurez quand même un
exemplaire un peu précieux un peu
particulier merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu
vous pouvez laisser un pouce inversé
c'est le cas vous pouvez donc retrouver
le lien vers le niveau sinon la
description je sais plus si je le dis au
palais le lien vers les places pour
l'olympia s'il vous voulez c'est un
cadeau de noël qu'on se retrouve à
l'olympia pour mon spectacle qui m'a est
ouf
aussi grâce à vous et c'est pour ça que
si vous n'êtes pas là ça marche moins
bien
abonnez-vous ci n'est pas encore fait je
l'avais déjà dit mais ça me fait plaisir
rendez vous demain matin à 6 heures
c'est le concept chaque
[Musique]